hey guys Pete here mr. robot season 2 is
getting ready to start with a 2 episode
premiere on Wednesday July 13th last
night though the USA Network did a
special special social media event where
they released the first episode for a
short period of time through their
various accounts I happened to be
watching the Facebook live event which
was an interview Q&A with the actors
that ended up being interrupted in such
a way to make it feel like eff society
was taking over the broadcast everyone
who was watching got to preview the
first episode prior to the premiere and
at the end there were links provided
that you could share with your friends
to watch it on the other accounts for a
short period of time it was a pretty
cool surprise and a nice way to kick off
the season if you missed the early
release you can just watch the 2 episode
become here on Wednesday this will be my
mr. robot season 2 episode 1 review so
be careful for spoilers if you haven't
watched the episode yet you don't want
to watch this unless you want to have it
completely spoiled come back after you
watch episode 1 and then you'll be able
to get a lot more out of this so we
start out with a flashback with Elliot
and Tyrell in the arcade executing the
evil core pack this scene takes place
during the three day period of time that
Elliot can't remember we learned that
Tyrell is help we learned that Tyrell is
helping Elliot and hear him on the phone
making sure the honeypot server is
reconnected to the network we see an
online convert conversation with white
roads coordinating the start of the
attack and then we see the exploit
commence we don't get any further
insight to Tyrells motives here or any
indication where they where they go
after the fact we don't we do see Elliot
reach into the popcorn machine and grab
the gun that was stashed there at the
end of the first season we then get a
flashback from childhood we see young
Elliot laying on the ground after being
pushed by his father and falling out his
own bedroom window we see both his
parents rushed to him and we see that
his father is genuinely upset and
worried we then see him at a doctor's
office and find out that he has a broken
arm and a mild concussion his mother's
overbearing personality is emphasized
here where she takes a jab at his father
for losing his job and asked about how
they will pay for the cost of the cast
from there we cut to the present and we
get a nice sort of montage that shows us
what Elliot is up to after the hack we
learned that he's staying with his
mother and following a very strict
self-imposed schedule in an effort to
keep mr. robot out of his mind we meet
his mother his friend Leon and some
other characters that he sees on a daily
basis this is peppered with a TV news
broadcast
where President Obama is discussing what
has been dubbed as the five nine hack we
hear that the hack is having devastating
effects on the economy and the tyrell is
implicated by named by the president as
we watch Elliott he explains that his
day started like every other day in the
last month since he started his program
the music is cool in Leon's dialogue
about Seinfeld is great we learned that
he attends a church group a couple
nights a week to socialize himself and
we and that he's keeping journals we
also find out that his mother doesn't
have a computer or internet too and his
words tempt him into the night but get a
small twist here when we realize he's
talking to krysta in the narration
instead of us the viewers and in her
office we learned that Elliot has chosen
to live with his mother because she is
too strict this person he knows and he
says that the devil you know is better
than the devil you don't know during
their exchange when pressed Elliot tells
krysta it isn't that he doesn't trust
himself it's that he doesn't trust him
referring to mr. robot he's talking
about how he doesn't want to go back to
his old life and she's basically asking
him whether he misses it or not we cut
away from this being in the office
before we get to find out if Christa
knows about his alternate personality
there we see Elliot returning home and
he addresses the audience for the first
time he says he knows we want to know
what he told Christa but he doesn't
trust us enough at this point he says
that we've kept information from him and
then when he goes inside we see mr.
robot for the first time in his room we
get a closer look at what he is
journaling and learned that he is
documenting everything that is happening
mr. robot is telling that telling him
that they still have work to do and that
a revolution needs a leader Elliot asked
mr. robot to tell more Tyrell is and mr.
robot says he can't do that
Elliot then tells him to go [ __ ] himself
and mr. robot uses the gun from the
popcorn machine to shoot him in the head
he falls back but he gets right back up
so you can tell that it's just some sort
of internal conflict we learned from the
journal that this is a recurring
recurring part of the loop like he's
shot in before but it isn't clear if it
happens every day or if mr. robot always
says the same things from there we get a
short scene with a character who looks
like Darlene wearing an F Society mask
she's on a mission to cut the balls off
the bull statue on Wall Street then we
cut to a new character and hearing her
up
go home then having problems with her
security alarm from there we see that
her smart home system is acting like it
has a mind of its own everything she
tries to do basically it just switches
back or you know she's trying to take a
shower and the water goes the water
temperature goes up really hot
she turns off the stereo the stereo
comes back on things like that she
realized that it's glitching out and
after calling the company she decides to
leave and stay at another house that she
hasn't Greenwich
as soon as she drives away we see two
people enter her home and find out
Darlene took control of her system so
that she could drive her away and that
they could move in we cut back to
Elliott's mom's place to find Gideon has
come to talk to him he explains that the
FBI is after him and thinks that he
would and that the FBI thinks that he
was the hacker or at the very least
complicit he asked Elliot if he has any
information that can help them while
Gideon is talking mr. robot starts in on
Elliot which makes him seem confused mr.
robot starts to press him and then
appears to cut getting its throat this
freaks Elliot out so he takes off which
which makes it so that everything is up
in the air and we don't really know what
getting its position is or what he's
going to do we get another shot in
Elliot's room where he's trying to stick
to his regimen and then go back to the
diner where Elliot is eating with Leon
again mr. robot is there and he tells
Elliot he's an organ that is vital to
his existence and Elliot resists and we
see the scene end by him asking us the
audience to just have hope for him we go
back to the house where the hackers took
over and we see the Darlene's upset with
the outcome of the hack there's a party
going on downstairs but she's all alone
and isolated upstairs she pulls herself
together and gives a speech to the
people at the party to remind them that
they are in a war we find out that the
house they are occupying belongs to
Susan Jacobs the general counsel of
ecore who has the nickname of madame
executioner we then see her giving out
orders and working on her computer
Mobley points out that she sounded a lot
like George W Bush in her speech and she
explains that it still feels like they
as in the people they hacked are winning
she asked him not to be half in like the
others and gives him a flash drive the
next scene is at an evil Corp Bank where
we see a customer's trying to close out
her account we learned the customers are
having a hard time accessing their money
and that evil Corp might not
have enough money to pay them out full
as the teller is trying to access the
account we find out that ransomware has
been installed which locked down the
system completely we see her call about
the problem and learned that Mobley is
on the inside working as an IT guy
the final scene in the episode takes
place in an office where we see the CEO
Phillip price the CTO Scott Knowles who
are waiting for Madame executioner to
arrive they all discussed the ransomware
and F society's demands in the end the
CTO volunteers to make the drop of five
point nine million dollars so that they
can get the encryption key to unlock
their system so episode 1 was a nice
start which gets things moving quickly
and it filled in some of the pieces that
you know we didn't have from the past it
sets up the ongoing struggle that
Elliott is facing now that he knows mr.
robot exists in his mind only at this
point his focus seems to be completely
on just trying to control this side of
himself but at the same time he can't
imagine he'll be able to stay where he
is for very long my favorite part of the
episode was probably the sequence where
we learn about Elliott's daily
activities you know the music how it was
all laid out with the Obama speech and
how that transitioned into the to his
appointment with Christa one of the
biggest mysteries we have in like one we
have no real idea about is how Andy
Elliot ended up in the situation where
he was obligated to meet with Christa in
the first place in season 1 when he was
in the hospital after falling off the
boardwalk it was pretty clear that he
didn't go like start seeing her
voluntarily for some reason he was sent
to her we didn't get much info about
tyrell or where he might be or what
happened in the three days after the
hack began were more importantly why mr.
robot won't give him that information we
do know that he is implicated by name
from the news report though and we don't
know how that's going to play out Elliot
was obviously as safe as someone could
be as far as the hack was concerned but
you know we can see that there's several
different ways that this could end bad
for him Tyrell is definitely like a
loose end and he's someone that knows
too much information about what happened
and you know what he gets taken down and
he's how's he not going to implicate
Elliot if we couple that with the
circumstantial information that Gideon
can provide to the FBI it would appear
that mr. robot is going to have to
succeed in getting Elliot out of his
mom's house well he's trying to regain
control of his mind he's at the same
time losing control of his ability
do anything about this situation he has
himself in everyone from F Society is
split up and we haven't seen what Romero
or Trenton are up to we also haven't
seen Angela at all but we did get quite
a few clips of her with Phillip price in
the trailers you know the CEO the other
main character doesn't appear in episode
1 is Joanna Wallach Tyrells wife most of
the preview stuff they put out before
the season seems to indicate that she
will be taking a bigger role in season 2
so what do you guys think can Elliott
exists off the grid for much longer
where is Tyrell and what is he doing
beyond that why did he work with Elliott
in the first place and was he really
truck just trying to get back at E Corp
for firing him what exactly is Darlene
extorting a geek or four will get Ian's
tip off the FBI about Elliott strange
behavior prior to the hack and who the
hell is Leon why does he eat at a diner
three for three meals a day in the
trailer we've seen that there's a new
character who's investigating the five
nine hack and we've also seen Elliott
getting grabbed and looks like he's
being held captive you know that it
originates inside his mother's house no
idea where that's going to come into
play but I have a feeling that you know
it's going to be tied to either Gideon
or Tyrell from everything I've read and
watch preparing for this season I'm
expecting that we will see the cast
dealing with the unexpected consequences
of their actions the reality of how
powerful how the powerful hold on to the
power that they have is really going to
test their resolve we are you know we're
already able to see this with Darlene
and I think there's been some
foreshadowing of it and Angela's story
even though she's sort of playing on the
other side you know she's trying to
climb the ladder one way and then f
society is trying to completely tear it
down so let me know in the comments and
post any questions you have there I'm
planning on doing an episode 2 review
after it airs and I'll also do a QA if
you guys have some good questions in the
comments please make sure you like the
video and subscribe to my channel if you
want to check out my future mr. robot
videos as soon as they come out talk to
you soon